this is a big win for the Congolese
government and East African troops in
North kivu Province to help combat M23
Fighters
the rebels took control of the area's
largest military base in October
Regional forces have been negotiating
with the fighters to withdraw we are
showing our Goodwill
giving hunting over kibumba then handing
over rumangabo
but we'll never continue to be
observersed while the all these are
taking place so we will react and we are
giving a last earning to the government
to the coalition
people continuing to persecute our
people and violating the process
fighting is fierce in some parts
government forces and the rebels have
accused each other of starting the
latest flare-up in masisi territory an
area rich in minerals
the rebels say they want to talk with
the government but kenshasa is reluctant
to engage it accuses Rwanda of
supporting M23 Kigali denies that the
question is not about trusting them the
question for us is to trust the process
and we know things must be very tough in
the ground but we strongly believe that
at the end of the day Rwanda because
Wanda is the one acting behind n23
thousands of Congolese are continuing to
flee from their homes
I tried going back recently with my
family but the rebels of M23 were still
around my home area in kibumba it's
still not safe for us so we decided to
return back to the camps
their houses have been raided they
cannot reach roads because of fighting
all this is a consequence of a conflict
that has nothing to do with them
Catherine soy Al Jazeera